perfect Sally Ride made history back in
1983 when she became the first American
woman to travel into outer space now
ride and three other women all NASA
pioneers are being honored with their
own likenesses the women of NASA lego
set went on sale this week and it
quickly became the top-selling toy on
Amazon the group of astronaut candidates
includes a number of first i'm mae
Jemison and i'm the first woman of color
in the world to go into space mae
Jemison figure stands alongside rides
next to a LEGO version of the space
shuttle but the toys don't just honor
astronauts also depicted astronomer
Nancy G Roman I started in s in 1959 was
six months old she was NASA's first
female executive and is often credited
with being the mother of the Hubble
Space Telescope which transmitted these
stunning pictures of deep space back to
earth computer scientist Margaret
Hamilton wrote the software code that
helped the Apollo 11 crew land safely on
the moon and just last year she was
awarded the Presidential Medal of
Freedom I wanted for this particular set
to focus on to NASA history the women of
NASA edition was originally thought up
by science writer Maya Weinstock she
submitted the plans to Lego in 2016 and
the project received a 10,000 votes it
needed to proceed in a little more than
two weeks by shrinking them down to a
little more than an inch weinstock hopes
to highlight their oversized
achievements you can never have enough
sense that really celebrate women who's
been underappreciated I'm in history one
small step for the toy industry one huge
step for womankind I just love this I do
too everything about it go get a set now
yeah a lot of people are